[Music]
on July 31 2023 news brook. Paul Rubens
The pioneering comedian and actor best
known as Pee-wee Herman passed away from
cancer on July 30th the Beloved
performer was just 70 years old and fans
and colleagues across the world are
devastated to hear that this
extraordinarily funny artist is no
longer with us shortly after the world
learned that Rubens had been living with
cancer for six years a statement
released with news of his death threat
please accept my apology for not going
public with what I've been facing the
last six years I've always felt a huge
amount of love and respect for my
friends fans and supporters I have loved
you all so much and enjoyed making art
for you Saturday Night Live original
cast member laraine Newman took to
Twitter to share her sadness over the
loss of her dear friend with whom she'd
been in the industry for decades she
wrote Paul and I first met in 1973 at
Cal Arts he remained friends for the
next 50 years not day to day just the
kind of friend that you can text out of
nowhere or have a three-hour lunch with
and don't get me started on the birthday
text you send them all day I feel sick
late night Legend Conan O'Brien also
mentioned Reuben's affection for
birthdays no tweet can capture the magic
generosity Artistry and devout silliness
of Paul Reubens everyone one I know
received countless nonsensical memes
from Paul on their birthday and I mean
everyone it's surreal comedy and
unrelenting kindness we're a gift to us
all damn this hurts it's abundantly
clear that whether or not these
celebrities worked directly with Rubens
his impact was absolutely gigantic
Natasha Leone a friend of Reuben tweeted
I love you so much Paul one in all time
thank you for my career and your Forever
friendship all these years and for
teaching us what a true original is I
meant to do that Saturday Night Live
Stand Out Sarah Sherman peppered her
tweet with heart emojis writing my
patron saint you invented everything you
created a world we all wish we could
live in cold weathers also weighed in on
Reuben's talents and kindness tweeting
oh man Pee-wee Herman has ridden off to
Heaven rest in peace Paul Reubens thank
you for giving us peewee you made yours
truly a fan and you were one of the nice
guys and I know seriously Reuben's
really really loves celebrating
everyone's birthdays according to Jimmy
Kimmel and David Hasselhoff Kimmel
tweeted poor Rubens was like no one else
a brilliant and original comedian who
made kids and their parents laugh at the
same time he never forgot a birthday and
shared his genuine Delight for silliness
with everyone he met my family and I
will miss him as for Hasselhoff had
known Reubens for years he wrote Paul
Rubens was a great friend he gave me the
Muppets for my birthday and never forgot
anyone's birthday for my class he was in
my class at Cal Arts we had the same
business manager he was always kind to
me and to everyone he will be missed
fellow comedy great Dave Foley known for
his work with the sketch troop Kids in
the Hall also tweeted about this loss
saying very sad to hear Paul Reubens
died I was a big fan and I was fortunate
enough to hang out with him occasionally
over the years always kind charming and
funny his creation Pee-wee Herman made
life brighter and sillier for us all
legendary comedian Steve Martin agreed
writing Peewee got his wish to fly
thanks for Rubens for the brilliant
off-the-wall comedy our boy Peewee
Morgan Fairchild she had a heartbreaking
tweet indicating that she knew something
was off with her friend I am devastated
to hear of the passing of my friend Paul
Rubens he kept counseling pension offers
to get together but I had no idea he was
suffering so much my love and white
light to him and his family writer and
director Paul feig also shared his
heartfelt condolences writing this is
devastating truly heartbreaking Paul was
such a comedy genius from his Letterman
appearances to his TV shows and movies
he was so original and hilarious and
such a sweet man too this is a huge loss
for comedy thanks for all the laughs
Paul Jennifer Tilly didn't have much to
say but her simple tweet spoke volumes
alongside a picture of her and Rubens
she simply wrote rest in peace Paul
Reubens you always made me laugh
[Music]